we're taking you back to sri lanka
because we are getting breaking news
from the parliament we were showing you
just uh about 10 minutes or so the the
feed from the parliament that is the
live picture right now where the
president the next president has in fact
been elected and we understand that the
parliament has voted to elect ranil
wickremessinga as the next president
he's in fact a six-time
prime minister and he's now been elected
as president this of course coming after
the political and economic turmoil
that the country
has been witnessing
we are
going to bring in our correspondence
before minell fernandez let's listen
into uh what's taking place in
parliament right now
uh gratitude to everybody in the house
it is not necessary to say that
[Music]
for the development of the country
new way forward
[Music]
national
to embark on a way forward
i also extend the same request to
the former president
who is also present here
foreign
[Music]
the presidency
a moment ago in parliament has been
elected and voted in as the next
president of sri lanka he will serve
until
2024. this is according to the
parliamentary vote that has taken place
in the last few minutes or so in
parliament he was addressing
the nation as well as parliamentarians
saying that the country is in a very
difficult situation and quote we have
big challenges ahead let's bring in
minelle fernandez joining us from
colombo so he rana wikimessinga was one
of the contenders manel was it expected
that he would be the person to take on
this top role
i can't
seeing her winning that vote
yeah sorry we seem to be having some
technical problems with audio but uh if
you can hear me uh the
acting president now formalized as
president of sri lanka by members of
parliament in that parliament vote which
concluded a little while ago in terms of
the breakdown of those 219 votes valid
votes that were cast this morning in the
house uh basically ronald vikram is
saying her
134 votes to the 82 votes secured by
dallas
now this was pretty much something that
analysts had expected
because of
all of the negotiations the backroom
dealings that we were hearing about
obviously the long arm of the rajapaksas
uh believed to still uh be very much at
play here so essentially ronald vikram
is singer according to many of the
protesters uh and that's one of the
reasons that they have such a lot of
anger and frustration about how he has
ascended to the highest position in the
land i mean this is a man who a little
over two years ago
lost his parliamentary seat he was voted
out of parliament by the people of sri
lanka he was unable to win a single seat
for his party the united national party
under his leadership at that general
election the only reason he is sitting
in parliament
is because he sort of entered through
the back door and won a seat for the
nationalist for his party and he secured
that policy he was named to that seat so
a lot of frustration and anger but in
terms of the vote that has taken place
this morning the legislators have chosen
obviously uh in favor of ranil vikrama
singha and uh obviously those
parliamentarians representatives of the
people but not really listening to the
people's mandate so what do we expect um
the reaction to be from the streets and
from from the people of sri lanka
because as you're saying wikileaks is
very much an ally of the rajapaksas
absolutely so in terms of the sort of
warnings or the indications from
protesters i mean we heard it
as as recently as in yesterday's
processions and protests again this
morning while people were waiting to see
how the election would go
that they would not take this sitting
down i mean literally when this entire
campaign against the government you know
when that patience really snapped of the
people uh saying that it was initially
focused on gotham rajapaksa the
president
he brought in ranil vikrama singh as the
replacement prime minister to his
brother mahindra rajapaksa who stepped
down to try and appease those protests
that didn't happen i mean for the next
few weeks of ronald vikram missing his
prime ministership people continued to
protest it it reached ahead with gotab
rajapaksa fleeing the country but people
say you know they're not going to be
fooled any longer now there is a state
of emergency you can probably see the
heavy security and police presence
there's a massive security cordon around
the parliament today
you do have obviously a sort of a
conciliatory note struck by ronald
vikramazinga he has appealed to the
other candidates who ran for the
presidency in parliament today as well
as the opposition leader to all come
together to sort of rebuild the country
particularly which is at its knees with
this massive massive economic crisis but
the fact remains that
this is coming from someone who the
people themselves have spoken and said
has no legitimacy so he does have this
remainder period of the term but it's
going to be a very uneasy term
particularly because the people of this
country are unlikely to accept his
leadership
talk
tell us more about um
the the real crippling economic
and financial crisis that has been
facing sri lanka and the suffering of
the people
i mean this is what p has really pushed
people to the edge uh sri lankans
generally
don't
really get heavily involved in the
day-to-day running of things and as much
as you know we've had the rajapaksas in
power for over a decade uh we've had
that uh sort of uh cabal if you like
which now people say you know were
corrupt they mismanaged the country
there were a lot of deals being done
with the rajapaksa and their allies
being the main beneficiaries but people
took it uh for a long time yes there
were a few sort of you know
sort of comments or the center junctions
but they didn't really stand up against
it but the moment it started affecting
you know their day-to-day lives the
cost of living is soaring there are most
families many families that are unable
to put three square meals on the table
whatever food that does make it to the
table is probably cheaper now has less
quality so they're really struggling the
medical sector is facing an acute
shortage there are hospitals that
doctors are running almost purely on on
on donations on well-wishers it
shouldn't be this way so what people
think and say is that yes they do agree
that there are problems there is you
know very difficult times economically
the pandemic really uh ate into a lot of
stability for people but if the country
hadn't been in such a shaky financial
position
it would have been in a far better
position to deal with this mess that we
wouldn't be on our knees we wouldn't
have a problem uh to the extent which
that say ministers have to be dispatched
to international capitals with a begging
bowl and this is what is making people
angry when a few years ago sri lanka
graduated from being a developing
country to a middle-income country we
were sort of projected to
achieve certain development goals and
and keep building but this has been
completely wiped away yes it is a
mixture of a certain amount of bad luck
in terms of a real crash of tourism uh
with the easter bombings in 2019 then
soon after the pandemic which shut down
the economy uh obviously after that you
also had debt uh which was unsustainable
unsustainable for many many years the
rajapaksas had been warned about it but
again with president gotabe rajapaksa
coming in a number of sort of
some very questionable decisions
slashing the tax revenue which many
people two years ago warned would cause
huge hardship for the people so because
of this we're having a real real
crisis for the people and this is what
has made them so angry and literally at
the end of their patients okay menel
thank you so much for that minel
fernandez is reporting for us from
colombo